I don't think people fight enough for  friendships like I really think it's  something worth fighting for for some  people I agree it's really nice to like  find people that have similar interests  as I get older I'm really looking for  those connections and one of them is my  friend Catherine Gilbert went to the  Gymboree class we kind of looked at each  other like hey we seem should we be  friends we could be friends why did that  happen you were in the same t-shirt or  like I think we had the same diaper bag  by the way it's super real when I see  someone wearing a Jets hat or Jersey  like I'm immediately like we should  probably be friends as I'm getting older  like my circle is becoming so small and  I much rather have really in-depth  conversations than to have a group of  friends we talk about fighting for your  own happiness people get happiness from  friendships